لقد شاهد العالم هذا الأسبوع
وانتظر لمعرفة المزيد عن
الدمار الذي تسبب في مساعدة مطلوبة في
تونجا ولكن فقط لماذا تندلع البراكين فعليًا
هذا سؤال أريد أن أفرج عنه
معك
لقد دمرت الانفجارات البركانية
المجتمعات لعدة قرون مما أسفر عن مقتل
عشرات الآلاف من الناس حولها
العالم ومع وجود حوالي 1500 بركان على الأرض
، فلا عجب أننا قلقون بشأن هذه
الجبال من الصخور المنصهرة ، ولكن لماذا
تثور
أكثر من 80 في المائة من
سطح الأرض فوق وتحت مستوى سطح البحر هو
بركاني وعميق تحت الصفائح التكتونية للأرض
يحدث معظم النشاط البركاني المتحرك دائمًا حيث
تصطدم هذه الصفائح
بعمق داخل الأرض ، ويكون الجو حارًا جدًا بحيث
تذوب الصخور ببطء وتتحول إلى صهارة
لأن المادة المتدفقة أخف
من الصخور المحيطة بها ترتفع
ثم عندما تتحرك الصفائح التكتونية
ترتفع الصهارة إلى أعلى  بعض
منها يدفع من خلال الشقوق في
سطح الأرض مثل الفتحات والشقوق
ويصل إلى السطح حيث يوجد  ar
تسمى الحمم البركانية ، أي نوع من الثوران الذي
سيحدثه البركان يعتمد على
خصائص الصهارة الرقيقة والسائلة مما
يعني أن الغاز الذي يحاول الهروب
يمكنه القيام بذلك بسهولة ، لذلك عندما يحدث
هذا ، ستتدفق الحمم من البركان
الذي رأيناه مع هذا  براكين هاواي
لأن الحمم البركانية تتدفق ببطء ، يمكن للناس
الابتعاد بسرعة ونادراً ما ينتج
عنها ضحايا ، لكن الصهارة السميكة واللزجة هي
قصة مختلفة تمامًا ، حيث توجد
مساحة أقل للهروب من الغازات ، لذلك
يتم احتجاز الغاز المتصاعد بالضغط في الصهارة
التي تنفجر بعد ذلك على السطح
يسمى هذا بالثوران المتفجر وقد
رأينا ذلك مؤخرًا عند
الانفجارات البركانية في تونجا وسابقًا عند
الجبال وهيلين في الولايات المتحدة ،
يمكن أن تكون الانفجارات البركانية المتفجرة
خطيرة ويمكن أن تدمر حطام رماد الحمم البركانية
كل شيء في طريقها
في بعض الحالات هذه الانفجارات
دفنوا مجتمعات بأكملها مثل جبل
فيزوف في بومبي وجبل بيليه في
مارتينيك ، وقد اندلع حوالي 500 بركان
منذ أن بدأنا في حفظ
يسجل العديد من حول حلقة النار
التي تنتقل من نيوزيلندا على طول
الطريق إلى أمريكا الجنوبية حيث معظم
مناطق الانغماس وحركات الصفائح عبارة
عن نشاط بركاني يتم
مراقبته عن كثب من قبل العلماء في جميع أنحاء العالم الذين
يتعقبون البراكين النشطة يمكن أن يكون
غير متوقع ولكن في كثير من الأحيان ليس كلها
يمكن لخبراء الحالات عادة رؤية علامات التحذير
وتنبيه الجمهور قبل الانفجار